staffing issues are continuing problem
for the clark county school district and
it doesn't seem to be getting any better
yeah so there's a program right now
though at unlv trying to fill a gap with
paraprofessionals bianca holman live at
unlv this morning with more on that
bianca good morning to
you hey good morning so unlv's
paraprofessional pathways program is a
program that is helping educators become
full-time teachers
transitioning into a teaching career so
there are hundreds of paraprofessional
and teachers aides here in ccsd and of
course also in charter schools and
private schools and they help make
learning possible for thousands of
students and also our students with
special needs while they may not be a
lead teacher that doesn't mean they
don't have the desire to there are
recent changes in law that allow people
to stay employed and obtain their
license unlv has a program to help
individuals have their own classroom one
day
by us being able to increase the number
of licensed teachers that are available
to the district that helps make sure
that
students are with folks who have the
confidence of the state that the
background needed to be the teacher that
helps what's really important though
about our group when we look at our
first cohort for example about 70
percent of our our ppp or
paraprofessional school support friends
are
university students that are students of
color and they match demographically
much more closely with the students in
ccsd
here are some details about the program
it's it's an accelerated program only
about a year courses are completed in
six to eight weeks and you they want you
to have an associate's degree or have 60
college credits but if you don't they'll
work with you there are in-person hybrid
and online class options to help fit
everyone's schedule because they know
you're working you probably have a
family and experience in the classroom
is credit towards your students to
student teaching credit excuse me
of course like i said it's not just for
ccsd teachers also we've got charter
school teachers out there and coming up
in the next half hour we're going to
hear from a paraprofessional that's in
the program right now and just how
impactful it's been for her and how it's
going to help her reach a goal that
she's had for years you definitely want
to stick around for that bianca holman
live local now